qu'est ce que ça veut dire
l'entrepreneuriat quand on travaille à
annabelle roberts est à la tête de son
entreprise une bibliothèque de formation
depuis dix ans ce matin cette canadienne
n'échange pas et ses collaborateurs ou
des futurs clients l'audience une classe
de terminale stg
pour moi on peut pas apprendre sans
échouer et donc en france on n'a ni le
droit d'échouer neil doit de réussir non
plus parce que si on a réussi et on
gagne beaucoup d'argent il faut le
cacher il faut pas en parler donc pour
moi c'est important que ces gens entend
et voit quelqu'un qui a fait un parcours
atypique qui n'a pas fait une grande
école mais qui a quand même pu réussir
sur un chemin parallèle annabelle
roberts participe au semaine de
sensibilisation des jeunes à
l'entrepreneuriat c'est la troisième
année que l'établissement saint cyrien
accueille un professionnel sortir du
court mais en restant dans nos locaux
parce que nous élèves aiment bien être
rassurés et dans une zone de confort
qu'ils connaissent mais les faire partir
en restant ici en fait et leur des
couleurs faire découvrir que à côté de
chez eux il ya des millions de personnes
qui ont des talents et qu'il faut les
rencontrer pour qu'ils puissent eux
aussi en développer ça nous a appris
beaucoup de choses
comment entreprendre à avoir confiance
en nous et c'est une très bonne
intervenante parce que elle nous a
partagé beaucoup de choses comme à
l'entreprise sans avoir peur j'ai appris
plein de choses au début je vais faire
travailler pour un patron mais je pense
que j'ai bien failli être le premier
parce qu'elle est je pense qu'on sait
plus qui me plaît en 2021 un peu moins
d'un tiers des entreprises en france ont
été créées par des femmes un chiffre
stable depuis 2000 19